dis moi toi tu es prêt toi aussi envie
de balancer à l'oreille après le
séminaire je veux quatre bons coups
chaque label choïgou d'abord j'espère
une attaque première fois des prêts 1
on est dans l'enfance dans les enfants
dans les mamans les papas ont envoyé
chez seat est le premier que tu as fait
avec une petite kaman a salué en lui un
tien
et fermement jouer ce jeu pipi c'est
très marrant je sais que c'était à moi
et mes potes avec le quiz mais c'était
vachement d'épouser un guide et parce
que moi c'est que je vais revoir
maintenant et que basso a cédé messieurs
vachement sérieux peut-être coup je m'en
souvenir votre choix
mais je me dis c'est gros mais ce
barbecue puis avec lui et l'isolément
banon il s'en souvient peas kings pc qui
s'en souvient absolument pas les genres
et disent à leur mémoire mais je crois
que les enfants jouent moins plus cuit
puis non on jouait beaucoup tu dis mais
pas ce que je fais
moi j'ai dû tout le temps quand j'étais
petit je mets aussi bien c'est me sens
pas que les enfants maintenant moi je
sais pas moi j'ai deux fils y est pour
le moins de son petit je sais pas encore
je te dirais que ça dans quelques temps
décines a dit le juge
elle des yeux
sûrement pas vraiment fait pas
maintenant la tête des premières boums
première boum première boum le 12 13 ans
qu'est ce que tu as fait rouler des
pelles pour aider c'est sûr on se serait
arrêtée là haut on avait très très bon
et est torché un peu non est ce qu'on
vivait à l'époque non au nom fut
immédiat non c'était des pétards du
prêteur des jeunes vraiment autre temps
veut plus vieux quand même moins treize
ans plus tard termine copine premiers
flirts c'était la premier flirt c'était
dans une boum
il ya eu baisers profonds où ça marche
et ben oui à élever le vrai décor hors
cac langues
la première fois que tu t'es retrouvé
toute nue avec un garçon a jeté choix
tenait à et lui donc
c'est sûr que ça sonnait tout droit sur
tout ouais c'est une douche 1
et puis l'arrivée sous la douche non
c'était ça a commencé en bas comme tout
bon que tous les garçons pierre mansat
s'est mis en route et ça m'a tellement
étonné que d'écouter la déconcentrer et
rafraîchit plus long donc on ne sait pas
si facilement quand même à l'époque
ouais bah justement on y arrive première
expérience sexuelle mais avec
pénétration c'est généralement ce qui
explique clairement de passion à ce
qu'est pas d'ambiguïté je sais pas si
j'ai une vie de famille j'ai trois jours
très très mignon fait j'étais très
amoureuse d'un garçon qui était très
amoureux de moi et on est restés
ensemble pendant cinq ans abazid
es-tu garde un bon souvenir de cette
première télé france annonce est
vraiment interdisons les choix comme
vous pleins pleins d'anadys à la
première fois tu dis quoi c'est ça c'est
un peu déçu et un peu d'issues première
expérience homosexuelle
l'expérience inédite à l'époque proche
de la génération il fallait tout ici
c'était est où ici alors on a tout
essayé même la tva est alors je me suis
dit et puis c'était vraiment un gars
n'avaient pas eu une histoire sa vie
sexuelle
moi ça ne disait rien du tout mais je
lui dis vais ouvrir que d'être ringarde
donc j'avais repéré une nana qui était
plus plus du gazon maudit tout pouvait
pas et je m'étais dit bon va falloir que
je me lève pas ça veut pas ça ne me dit
rien du tout il faut que j'aille quand
même tu vois et puis j'y suis allée
malheur bourré comme un coing et puis je
ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
le seul truc les méandres d'un matin
elle m'a dit elle même n'est pas une
affaire ah ouais t'as pu recommencer si
ça m'avait fait ça m'avait pas beaucoup
plus et puis surtout c'était pour
l'avoir fait toi moi je les fais je suis
si la fédé troqué je suis tranquille
première par tous ça c'était
j'étais les jeunes tu vois quoi
maintenant ils sont comme ça les autres
points c'est mal
c'était dans le sixième jeu ses grands
parents je crois pas qu'il ya mieux à
faire face il ya un an c'était chez sa
camarade camarade qui me dit viens on va
chez des amis boire le verre la fatwa
ans et je cherche des culottes 16e
non non pas du tout je ressentais un
petit ami de l'époque et tout puis on
arrive dans cette boue mais on était
jeunes on avait 15 16 ans tu vois il y
avait des matelas partout on était les
premiers mois j'ai pas vu le trou
devenir toi et puis au bout d'un moment
vont les gens commencent un peu tu as a
flirté tout ça mais bon c'est dit c'est
dit bonsoir je vois un peu fort mais
après tout à la fois la communauté
grecque ont commencé à s'adapter et au
bout de deux heures
toulouse était franchement à paul est
avec moi qui va te rochette a pas de
calcul et puis là il m'a dit quand même
vachement coincé comme nana et vous
et là j'ai dit ouais je cherche mon coin
c'est comme nana et a rien fait non nous
a regardés non non non je suis parti
j'étais assez non non je te promets non
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui voilà ok on
continue deuxième temps complet alors la
première cuite
alors je suis souvent bourrés qu'est ce
que je vois pas beaucoup donc je suis
très très vite bourré et comme les gens
qui boivent pas beaucoup je suis vite
vos amis des jeunes à problèmes aux os
oui ont sûrement oui je sois plus bien
premier pétard alors ben une la mère
d'une copine de classe dont 1 co 12 ans
ou là un petit peu tawes états unis et
l'europe états fautifs à son expérience
de 12 ans sita foot avec le recul c'est
particulier vont fouler juin ouais
premiers acides jamais ce sont vingt ils
n'ont jamais d'asteel parce que j'ai
vraiment là je trouve que les mecs qui
avait fait tellement collé au bol vous
appelez un wagon quand même mon corps
est et on les connaît bien
cette dernière comptant vous oubliez
c'est vous voyez je veux